hi there I'm sorry we're getting off to
a bit of a slow start but so this past
summer I was kind of lucky enough to
start my journey into data science with
the Microsoft data science summer school
which is held at microsoft research here
in New York City we kind of spent the
first four weeks of the eight-week
program program learning about various
algorithms and methods for data science
as well as languages like Python at our
and then the second four weeks we
started our own research projects that
we were supposed to present at the end
of the eight-week stretch so the project
I walk worked on was called the cost of
Public School in New York City and it
was focused on public schools right here
in New York City's five boroughs for
those who might not live here in NYC and
we have a zone school system for public
schools that have kindergarten through
eighth grade so what it means is that
essentially lawmakers kind of
arbitrarily draw lines on a map and they
determine which addresses get to go to a
particular school if you don't live
within that zone your child cannot
attend that school and has and must
either go to private school which has of
course tuition or go to their own zone
school which is determined by the nap so
um while this doesn't really seem like a
big deal or off the bat New York City
has some of the best and worst schools
in all of New York State and in all of
the country and some are pretty much
right next to each other this is a graph
we made during the program that shows
the school performance by school zone
the blue is good and the red is bad and
if we zoom in we can see this effect in
action ps11 here in midtown west perform
worse than sixty percent of schools in
all of New York State and PS 59 which is
a 10-minute walk away is the 19th best
school in the state so this kind of
raises a lot of issues for you know the
community especially when the depart
education proposes changes in boundaries
so for example if the boundary between
these two schools were shifted one a
couple of blocks in one direction it
would mean that children who had been
attending a high-performing school are
now required to attend a very poor
performing school and if we go back to
the previous map you'll notice that low
performing schools are kind of
centralized in recognizable areas such
as the Bronx parts of Brooklyn like
Bushwick canarsie East New York
flatlands Crown Heights essentially
low-income parts of the city with lots
of low-cost housing and meanwhile those
looking for an apartment to move or a
house to move with their family well
have noticed a sharp increase in price
within the same neighborhood for school
zones that are known for better schools
and so with these in mind we drafted our
hypothesis and got to work all right so
what was our question we already knew
that housing costs disparity and
education disparity in New York City
coincided but by how much specifically
we wanted to know what portion of the
housing costs in a given zone was
associated with the quality of the local
school and we wanted to put a number on
that in our case since we were all
pretty knowledgeable about New York City
all being from New York City and we kind
of skip past wondering about the truth
of our statement and went directly to
thinking of a way to demonstrate and
quantify it for for you guys who are
kind of starting out if you know you
might actually have to go into that
thought process about whether your
hypothesis is true especially if you're
thinking about a community that you
don't know very well or or otherwise
disconnected from societies change
pretty quickly and the best we can do is
capture a small snapshot in time in 10
or 5 years you know even all the
information that we recently came up
with Mike drastically change and if
gentrification in New York City keeps
going as fast as it goes five years
might even be
a really large amount that said you know
maybe what you're working on can make a
difference right now but you have to
make sure that the the question you're
answering is relevant and current to the
community that you want to help so kind
of the first thing that we thought of
was imagine this perfect world with
unlimited data all clean which you know
as a day of Sciences we all pretty much
know is completely impossible but we can
dream so in a perfect world how would
you demonstrate the answer to your
question for us we decided that an ideal
experiment would be to sell two
identical apartments in the same
neighborhood directly across the school
zone from each other and compare the
prices and the zone at the better school
should show a measurable increase in the
price and we decided to normalize for
the size of the apartment by taking the
price per square foot rather than just
the the flat price so um you know from
there we we had to break down this ideal
problem which we can't really do you
know can't really make two identical
apartments kind of directly across from
each other so we had to break down this
problem into the realm of possibility we
wanted to get housing data from each
school zone control for features of the
housing get an average price for the
various types of housing in the zone and
then compare it with the average price
of neighboring school zones in the same
neighborhood so essentially if you're in
Park Slope park slope's pretty ritzy
area for the most part the neighborhood
is going to have similar features which
would allow us to control for certain
things like proximity to the subway or
or proximate to various jobs commerce
various things that people look for when
they're trying to buy an apartment
unfortunately that was what we would
like to do if there was unlimited data
and we did not have unlimited data or
even you know a substantial amount of
data
so in your case you want to detail your
ideal experiment and then break it down
into smaller and smaller pieces based on
what you can actually acquire which
leads us to what can you actually
acquire high quality data as we all know
and computational time are in short
supply with few exceptions particularly
in social science fields where the
research just has it been done yet where
people haven't thought to collect data
on certain things or collect data well
on on certain things even are you know
more realistic idea to solve this this
problem was just not possible because of
the limited amount of data and so we had
to cut this down even further to
consider what data we could get within
our four-week time limit while still
remaining true to the problem so for the
cost of public school project we kind of
looked at these things as necessary to
stay true to the meat of what we wanted
to find what data do we need on housing
we knew that it wouldn't really make
sense to compare a three-bedroom
two-bathroom apartment price with a one
bedroom one bathroom apartment price and
so we needed to know the features of a
particular piece of housing as far as
bedrooms bathrooms the square footage
and we needed the address to place it
inside a school zone and we needed the
square footage as I mentioned since
we're we're measuring price per square
foot and of course we actually need a
sale price and we needed a sufficient
amount of these in each school zone to
be able to get some kind of decent
average so what types of housing could
we acquire and how will the data we
can't get affect the impact of our
experiment so this is thing that I kind
of had a fight with my supervisors eval
about a little bit during the program
and that was that um we ended up only
including a housing or apartments sales
we really could not find
a reliable source of rental data that
included all the features that we knew
we needed to include and that would have
maybe we could have done some web
crawling but as far as the time limit it
wasn't really feasible considering what
we had to do and then on top of that
cleaning data from web crawling is even
worse than cleaning data that you got
from an API so in the in the end we
ended up just completely eliminating
rental data but we felt that the sales
data should reflect what the rental data
would have given us and so we felt that
though it did detract in some way it
should we should still stay we should so
end up with a result that would carry
over once rental data was able to be
included so what other factors could
affect housing costs so like I was
saying about the three-bedroom
two-bathroom compared with a one-bedroom
one-bathroom you know it'd be a problem
to compare an apartment located in an
area like Midtown East to one in the
South Bronx or crown heights you know
Midtown uses is pretty big it's it's you
know it has a name for itself as a ritzy
area and so regardless the prices there
are going to be increased versus again
the South Bronx or crown heights even if
the actual apartments themselves are
comparable so the exact neighborhood and
its features would drastically affect
the housing costs and we needed to
include that in our model we would like
to include more things like proximity to
parks and other small things that
especially families might be considering
when they're looking for a place to live
with their kids but again in the
interest of time we were unable so what
you guys should do is definitely make
sure that you know exactly what you need
out of your data set to do your
experiment and potentially be willing to
commit to more or less features
depending on what data is available to
you if you have a time limit absolutely
make a list of improvements that you can
include later on after you've kind of
done the meat work on a
a portion of the day that you really
would have liked to collect so the data
you've made your decisions about what
your data needs to look like and now you
actually have to try to get some so
community data sites can be really great
if your community has one in New York
City we have NYC open data which for
collecting school information worked
really well and for collecting housing
information worked really poorly we
ended up with the probably one of the
worst situations we could find as far as
the housing data we're in everything was
stored at all the details of each piece
of housing was stored in a PDF hand
written form no not the head retina pdx
well like just about the worst thing you
know for a data science to say a
scientist to find is that their their
data that they really need is brain in
chicken scratch on some form and then
scanned into a computer and then stored
in a PDF and you know we're slowly
developing you know handwriting you know
algorithms that can tell what's there
but that's another mess that a lot of
times it's just not enough time to
really deal with so with that in mind we
kind of have to move to third party
sites and my G this is assuming that you
don't have like some some luck and you
know the government is like oh we're
handing out this data that you know we
were just giving away for free for
example new york city recently released
all of their turnstile data for the
subways so if you are doing a project on
that great you already have your data
it's it's fairly clean it looks nice for
us this data was really not anywhere
that the city was providing so we had to
look to third party sites to get a
decent data set so the problems with
third party data sites is that many of
them are not really free and clear to
use even for a research project for a
student or you know just any kind of
social science nonprofit based type
research
you really have to check the terms and
most of the time they'll tell you that
maybe you can you can get some portion
of the data for free and then you have
to you know you know pay some price or
you have to get some special key it's a
special access so there can be a lot of
barriers to getting information through
a web sites API of course you can always
just crawl the site but again there are
issues that come with your your data
quality through doing that the API could
just be slow and in general pulling data
from the web can be slow and on top of
that if you do have an API you know want
to respect the site giving you your data
by pausing in between your calls so that
you're not kind of just swapping them
for us it took us about two or three
nights of just leaving a desktop on all
night long to get the initial data set
which was about 40,000 lines and you
know we ended up using a site street
easy to collect our housing data along
with all the details so fixing your data
sometimes your research needs
researching as with all freshly
harvested data due diligence is required
to clean it up preliminary preliminary
data exploration is important to make
sure what you have makes sense and of
course since is a very broad term it
depends all your community and your
project you may need to do further
research just to make sure what you have
makes sense and we definitely were
constantly going back to the web to
cross reference data that we had with
other sites so for example if we you
know saw data for a particular school
and we were unsure of whether or not
that school was really poorly performing
or or better performing there are other
sites that that you can use to get more
specific data on the school that are not
necessarily easy to pull data directly
from well the data looks okay so
this definitely turned out to be a huge
problem for us because our cursory
summaries of the data you know grabbing
your means your medians quartiles ranges
they didn't really show anything
particularly strange however there were
quite a few anomalies definitely check
for duplicate data lines especially if
you're pulling for it an API and also
look for wrong information that is
obscure to the point that it actually
looks realistic and they're they're not
that easy to find so um in our case we
did not notice anything strange until we
started to try to build a model we
looked at the the results and in some
cases so we were doing kind of a we
would split the data into two groups 80
and 20 and trained on eighty percent and
test on twenty percent and for some of
those splits which we which we did at
random we would end up with some very
strange-looking graphs that just didn't
really mesh what we thought should
happen and you know even though we kind
of did some basics to the data like
getting rid of missing information in
the bedrooms and the bathrooms or having
0 square footage or no no measure for
square footage at all we found that some
of the agents who I guess input in the
data on streeteasy with sometimes just
kind of list arbitrary numbers for the
square footage for absolutely no reason
and so we found quite a few lines of
data where in the square footage was
like 10 square feet and for one of them
we found it with one square feet one
square foot and it was like a 20 million
dollar residence so every time that
particular thing ended up in our test
data our models would just fly all over
the place and it ended up in the
training data we were actually closer to
looking realistic so we had to kind of
run this model several times just to see
okay it ran okay this time
I'm these numbers look good you're right
ok this time these numbers look good and
then other times y ry on my number solo
all of a sudden you know it you know our
R squared was coming out at like 10 like
like point 19 if the this particular
anomaly got caught in the wrong set so
in addition that kind of put a lot of
the square footage is that we did have
to question how many of them were really
you know kind of just vague estimates
and particularly toward the smaller end
so in New York City that's that's they
can get even more difficult because what
if you have kind of a place that's like
500 or 600 square feet you know tiny
living is kind of common in New York
City so there there may very well be
places that are quite small but still
fairly expensive and it's it's hard for
us to kind of eyeball and tell so at a
point you you kind of just have to you
know use your knowledge of the community
that you're dealing with to make sure
that your data is making sense or as
much sense as you can possibly get it to
make you know given what what data
you're able to get so due to the issue
with the square footage we actually lost
quite a few days of work um which was
really terrible um but you know what
this this basically means is that
reasonable results just don't always
mean you have good data we you know for
the first several tries of the model we
had decent looking results and then you
know that somebody decided well let's
try it just one more time and that's
when our results kind of you know
self-destructed research like I said
research on your community and on the
specifics of your community is really
important but you know as far as using a
third-party data site sometimes you know
they have their own data standards and
they're not yours absolutely not and
they also have you know things that they
find important that not only aren't what
you find important but are
even necessarily what you think they
should find important so you know you're
thinking streeteasy is a site you know
that's listening houses they might want
to get their square footage correct or
not apparently so in addition we found a
lot of duplicate lines of data that were
changed by one field but not a field
that we actually needed as far as the
data we were as far as the results we
needed to calculate so they had like a
separate field that involves like a
mixture of this school zone and the
borough that the school was in but
occasionally we get the same school in
two different boroughs so for those
apartments and houses that kind of lay
on a line we would end up having doubles
of those in the data and we thought like
we chose Street easy because we thought
okay they're letting us actually search
their API using school data which would
save us the time of actually having to
get addresses give them latitudes and
longitudes and then match them with
shape files and basically put them into
schools on ourselves unfortunately we
ended up having to do that anyway
because most of the school zones were
just completely completely wrong so you
know don't learn this the hard way and
spend you know a really long time on it
like we did definitely do your best to
check for small things like that that
just don't show up in your aggregate
data and your aggregate statistics so
the model yay finally we can kind of
start doing some real data sciency stuff
so um you have as much data as you can
get for the project that you want to do
your preliminary digging and has given
you what all data sciences love to see
which is a clean data set unfortunately
in our case this pretty much meant that
we squashed our original 40,000 lines to
less than a quarter and in certain parts
of the city we had almost nothing for
example in queens by the end I think we
had maybe 12 lines of data for all of
Queens which is the largest borough
so it's pretty terrible and so for you
you'll have to decide do you want to try
to find more data or do you want to
model maybe the the data that you're
missing given what you do have so for us
our model wasn't created to kind of give
us direct results but instead was used
to create kind of a quote-unquote fake
data set that would allow us to actually
compute the the premium associated with
the the school zone attached to your
housing costs so where we were going to
use this false data set which was built
on our training data to actually compute
this average with both within a school
zone and over neighboring school zones
in the same neighborhood so problems
with this approach so the graph on the
left here is the kind of a graph that
shows you where the school zones in New
York City are you can kind of see that
the lines are blocked out gray areas are
areas of New York City that are not
zoned or have not had a school test
given in a very long time so New York
City has like their own way that they
give out the exams to the schools that
determines whether or not they'll be in
the data so the graph on the right is
our our apartments that we manage to
pull our apartments or houses that we
manage to pull one dot / actual
apartment or house so you can see that
kind of in Queens there's like nothing
and in the Bronx it's very sparse staten
island gets gets pretty sparse and as
you kind of expect for a site that's
focused on you know selling we're
focused kind of in brooklyn and
manhattan which are you know kind of
hopping places to live in new york city
at the moment so you know street easy as
i mentioned before has its own agenda
its own agenda and you know it's a site
that kind of appeals to realtors in
people looking for houses so they're
focused in areas that are you know
really up-and-coming where there are a
lot of sales happening right now and so
we decided that oh well another issue is
that they're listing a listing price so
this is not the price that a place
necessarily sold for it's just what it's
currently being listed for which is
likely to be on the higher end and so we
definitely believe that at the end are
our numbers are scaled a little bit
higher also I believe that's that's a
consequence of excluding rental data but
again we believe that as far as the
actual results we should find similar
results regardless and so we kind of let
it go again given our time constraints
so it'll be up to you whether or not
your current data set can still
accurately depict what you want and at
this point you may decide that is
necessary for you to get more data but
again you know that's that's based on
you know your research in your community
and you know either way you should
definitely document places where you
feel your lapsing so this was our actual
model it's just a simple linear
regression model with various features
of the apartments to estimate the price
per square foot we also included the
school scores because we needed to
eventually control for those as it turns
out we did kind of two different things
we both tested the name of the
neighborhood and the distance from a
particular address to the subway it
turns out those are about equivalent as
far as accuracy in the model so that was
something that I just found really
interesting so the analysis so first
things first have a diverse team to do
your your analysis variety helps catch
errors
you know it's it's more than just your
flat numbers you not only have to know
what they mean but what they mean for
the community in question personal
experience can be really big and kind of
just finding like places where you might
have fallen in some areas so for example
we actually had former Realtors who were
now researchers and you know we would
ask them okay you know for this
particular area we know you sold a lot
in this area do these numbers look
correct as far as our price per square
foot and you know we got a lot of
affirmatives of course where we were on
New York City residents so we also had
our own idea of what things look that
looks like in our area and that just
helps you like avoid various problems
that may come up before you really get
like down to business and your analysis
so the people aspect the reason you're
doing you know social science conscious
research is because you're hopefully I
hope that you guys are thinking about
people you're thinking about how to help
people maybe how to help your own
community help other communities and
people should be integral to any
analysis that you do in our case we
definitely found that our numbers we're
reflecting lived experience of people in
New York City and we could use our
experiences in that as guides to make
our next decision and just decisions on
how we handle data what data we gathered
what was most important so I will say it
once again don't forget the community
that you want to serve they should be
driving your research direction it
doesn't seem like the most scientific
thing to do but too often you know as
people in tech and people in science you
know where we get separated from even
our own community that we had as kids
and we really don't end up serving them
at all we kind of just do it because
this is this our job or this is we just
like to do it you know analysis I'd like
to look at data but you know when you're
thinking about social science constant
conscious research really don't forget
the people who are you know who you're
doing this for and you know where you're
coming from in in you know whatever you
decide to do your research on for me you
know education disparity in New York
City is huge I was lucky you know I got
into tons of honors programs as a kid so
I never had to directly deal with it but
you know many people do many people who
look like me still do and you know
anything that I can do to help is
important to me and I don't want to end
up in a situation where I forget you
know why I'm here in the first place and
you know definitely you should make sure
that what you have is reflecting you
know what the community is is is telling
you and if it's not if you know your
your results do not reflect live
experience think about why try to come
up with reasons why you know it could
mean that you have an error in the very
question the way frame to the question
your data set or even your analysis and
use the community to your advantage
rather than working against them Jose
you know it's very easy to kind of be
like well this science says this but in
social science research you know it gets
very vague you know when you're dealing
with this society that's ever-changing
you know they're there are a lot of
things that just can't be quantified as
specifically as we'd like and there are
a lot of things that very easily get you
know turned on their head in the next
year or a few more months you know and
and while it doesn't necessarily mean
that you'll have to kind of restart your
whole project it's it's something that
you need to pay attention to and you
know if you're again if you're thinking
about serving your community not paying
attention to what they're saying could
really like it could work against them
which is a huge in my in my opinion is
pretty unethical but yeah let you you
know make your own decisions on
ethics of that and even if your research
does you know reflect live experiences
of people in the community make sure
that you've included every angle there
were a lot of things that I really
wanted to include as far as neighborhood
features in particular that we just
really didn't get to do because of time
and what that was one of the things that
I kind of listed in our you know to do
pile for our next run and that's
something that you should definitely
keep track of and try to include if you
you know eventually get access to the
data so don't fret if things do go wrong
even if you've kind of made it all the
way to the end of your analysis you know
social science research can take they
could do a very long time because of the
fluidity of society and people and
people kind of they give us a time data
but you know most of it is completely
it's Anna formet that we can't really
use and we'll just never really have
enough data on on human beings that will
satisfy you know any project that we
really want to do but what we can do is
open the door for more research to be
done and hopefully adore to meaningful
and lasting social change so I just want
to give a thank you to my team at
Microsoft who worked on the project with
me glenda Anastasia Thomas and our lead
Jake Amit and jen and then also Jennifer
who like ran the program for us and to
everyone who encouraged me to give this
talk to my first talk ever so I was like
really nervous and thank you to all of
you for coming and so I am a student at
Queens College graduating in May so if
you have questions comments or you want
to recruit please feel free to contact
me and that's it guys
do you think there would have been well
you started off by talking about
comparing trying to get more apples to
apples comparison just using the streets
that sells a force IV which would have
isolated things typically you wouldn't
have cared as much about subways or
other closer to the parts would there
have been enough data do you think so
Lee may be in manhattan to adjust and
eric properties on his criteria or just
on the barriers school district so
there's not not something so we actually
did really closely zoom in on park slope
because that was where we had like the
most people who knew the most and we had
a fair amount of sales in park slope and
so we actually did find a pretty
staggering difference between two areas
in Park Slope one was actually closer to
the subway and one farther away the one
farther away had a better school and the
price there was I think larger per
square foot by 83 dollars so you know
you're thinking for an extra thousand
square feet you're paying in two
thousand dollars more than the other
schools and so we we did in some cases
you know really isolate it down to where
we had a lot of data I think that if we
had probably gone specifically to
Manhattan or certain areas in Brooklyn
we might have been able to kind of get
more of that like immediate staunch
effects but I think it would be pretty
difficult just because the the idea is
that we would literally have to have
kind of a three-bedroom two-bathroom
apartment with blah features right
across the street from a three bedroom
apartment with blah features yes
create differences in school we did
specifically by the zone so zones are
smaller than the district he talked
about when vs. owning it's hard to get
the data on rent what did you think
looking at in a community the percentage
own versus renting and some other
variable that would impact the school so
that was something again that was
something that I argued with my
supervisors with a lot because I felt
that particularly in certain areas there
are just a lot of renters in certain
areas versus a lot of buyers and without
kind of having some sense of the rentals
I felt that our numbers would be skewed
so it was something that we decided that
while my super reservoir that we didn't
have enough time to include but it was
something that I definitely wanted to
tie in the price for a three you know
how do you know that but purely the
percentage of homes rented truly
percentage rent versus own not the
actual price per square foot yeah we
weren't even sure we would start trying
to collect that data either so yeah at
this point we were already two weeks in
and we had just gotten a clean data set
and then we you know we changed our
model about five times toward the end so
unfortunately time limits really cut us
down as far as doing much with the
rentals sorry guys you can feel free to
you know we can step out and guys can
ask questions